aktuell interessiert natürlich muss man
so sagen jedes detail über den
mächtigsten mann der welt
jetzt hat sich donald trump langjähriger
leibarzt zu wort gemeldet ein gewisser
dr
er hat der new york times verraten dass
der präsident wohl regelmäßig ein
präparat namen chinas beriet schluckt
ursprünglich ein polster mittel hilft
aber vor allem gegen männlichen
haarausfall
so was macht diese pille mit einem das
eine ganz wichtige frage denn die
nebenwirkungen die betreffen uns hier
indirekt alle wenn es getestet
finasterid für uns in selbstversuchen
neben dem heute schon labors denn es wie
ist denn so ihr erster eindruck davon
ich kann meine haare wieder auf dem
tragen
mach ich mir strähnchen machen danke das
gerät hat mir die würde zurückgegeben
das freut mich und was es jetzt mit den
nebenwirkungen haben die mich zugehört
ich hab die der hgv nebenwirkungen
laut studien sind da schon ein paar
risiken vier haben wir denn da herr
kopfschmerzen depressionen
das wahre leben kraft nah an die besten
störungen verlangsamte denkprozesse den
tag nicht verstanden es verstanden
angststörungen und starke schwitzen
außerdem greift massiv in den
hormonhaushalt ein stichwort impotenz
zugegeben das ist keine gute nachricht
im zusammenhang mit tram das
gefährlichste der welt ist nun mal ein
70-jähriger der keinen mehr hoch krieg
eines von fünf hässliches wort taubheit
der roten sack keine reaktion mehr auf
sexuelle reize meinen informale
laborassistentin die könntest du mir
nackt vor den bauch binden
dazu technik habe ich die ganze zeit
bieten unbändige drängen
ich weiß auch nicht eine mauer zu bauen
oder muslime zu beleidigen der verband
macht einfach mehr spaß nicht
[Applaus]
gute besserung